So let's say we have this code where again
R1 is compared to 0, and we branch here
if it's equal to 0. If it's not equal to 0, we do this and branch out. If it
is equal to 0, we do this and continue.
We have seen that this code results in four instruction's
worth of execution, when we have the conditionals MOVs.
Two instructions that actually do the work of ADDIs. And
two instructions that conditionally write results back to R2 and R3. With full
predication, a la the Itanium, we get the condition check
is done using the predicate set instruction that
compares equal zero on R1 and sets P1 and
P2 accordingly. The predicates are always set opposite of each other so
that if R1 is zero P1 is set to true and P2 to false. If
R1 is not equal to 0 then P1 is set to false and P2 is set to true. Now we can
simply do the add i of 1 plus r2 into r2. But we will predicate it with p2,
so that it only gets done if r1 was
not equal to 0. And then, this instruction becomes
exactly what it was here. Except that now it's predicated so that it only gets
done if r1 is equal to 0. So as you can see with this, after we do this
initial instruction that simply sets the predicates, any
code that was here simply gets predicated with
one of the conditions. The opposite condition predicates
the other branch's code. And that means that first
of all we can use the same registers that we
used before. We don't need the additional R4 and R5
that we had in the previous example. And second, we
still do have the work of both parts. But there
is no additional work to now move the results into
the registers, the type of destination registers. So the overhead
here is kind of similar to what we had with branches.
With branches, we needed to have the branch, and then the
code from either pass. Here we have the condition set, followed from the
code from both paths. So the only really overhead that we have in terms
of executing more instructions, comes from doing the work of both paths instead
of just one. But there are no
additional instructions to select between the results.